what's up everyone persia here and today
is all about
xbox we got our first look at halo
infinite gameplay
and we got a lot of insight and reveals
from
first party and third party games too so
we're going to be talking about that
and a whole lot more on today's saves
date for thursday july 23rd
[Music]
right out of the gate and as promised we
got our very first look at halo infinite
gameplay
in typical master chief fashion we
crash-landed into a mission
which seemed to be the tip of the
iceberg for infinite's new adventure
from the gameplay the rumored grappling
hook was confirmed
we see the sprint mechanic alive and
well and the world
itself looked massive not only will the
world of halo infinite be larger than
both halo 4 and 5 combined but microsoft
has already promised bigger battles than
ever before
and hinted at all new gameplay mechanics
that have yet to be seen in the series
the first look at competitive
multiplayer is said to be revealed in
the upcoming months
and i'm super curious to see how that's
going to round out the full halo
experience on next-gen
based on what we've seen so far what do
you guys think
halo wasn't the only new thing we got to
see today because 9 out of the 15
xbox game studios had something to
reveal during today's showcase
let's start with some of the first party
games the grand finale of the showcase
revealed what's been rumored for years
a brand new fable is on the way the
trailer was completely cinematic and
conveyed a quirky tone for the game
but offered no further details on
gameplay or release date
it's considered a new start for the
franchise and will be developed by
playground games
we also saw quite a few world premieres
like state of decay 3
a vowed and a brand new very beautiful
forza
along with many other reveals we even
got more insight on a few titles we've
seen before
like hellblade 2 and my personal
favorite
everwild some of the third party
announcements ranged from world
premieres to
reveals that some of our favorites are
making their way to next-gen
and surprisingly even more than that for
the first time on console soccer 2 was
announced with a spooky
cinematic trailer which showed
mysterious anomalies
crushing cars and abandoned contaminated
areas
the trailer ultimately confirmed the
revival of the series after being
dormant for over 10 years
we got our first look at a new outer
world dlc which will be available on
other platforms too
titled peril on gorgon the game's first
big expansion takes you to the gorgon
asteroid taken over by marauders
and is said to have new specialized
skills that will appeal to outer worlds
veterans we have a full interview with
game director carrie patel on
gamespot.com if you want a deeper dive
on peril and gregan
we also learned of new details on other
titles like
jack black's involvement with
psychonauts 2 as not only a voice actor
but a musician
and even the fact that destiny 2 is
making its way to game pass
and it includes all the expansions
needless to say there is a lot to unpack
when it comes to the xbox game showcase
but don't worry
because we've got you covered just go to
gamespot.com if you want to learn more
about each and every game that they
featured this morning
while you're there consider stopping by
our merch store because we have a bunch
of awesome play for all goods
that you can purchase and those proceeds
will go directly to black lives matter
and kovid 19 relief efforts thank you
guys so much for watching feel free to
give me a follow on twitter at persia
underscore xo
and please have a happy and safe weekend
so we can see you again on monday
for your next save state take care
[Music]
you